thanks fellas handy
I like this set
very nice we this is very cool they went
to a lot of trouble yep we got palm
trees we got a little Formosa cafe right
here yeah but you know what that door
doesn't open I've tried yeah definitely
to get a drink yeah we didn't see the
tiny waitresses yeah this is not jody's
comfortable I love these these are nice
but I've been told careful they're
rented all right you know we were all
ranking yes just a short time you know
this is a big opportunity for us to come
to Los Angeles we've never done our show
in LA we never did our show anywhere no
a week in Staten Island a few years ago
no one was watching thank you for seeing
that yeah
he wasn't even broadcast they were they
were rowing by well anyway we thought
Andy and I thought since we're out here
we got to make the most of this I mean
let's face it we're on at 12:30 and we
thought we got to go for a real job
while we're in Los Angeles all right
real jobs real show primetime television
real money real yeah the big money yeah
yeah so we thought what we do is we
would go and pitch a show to the most
powerful TV producer in Hollywood Aaron
Spelling that was our thought this guy
this guy has produced he has produced so
many hits Beverly Hills 90210 Melrose
Place Love Boat your personal favorite
dynasty my personal favorite Fantasy
Island just to name a few we thought
let's go and see this guy all right
let's really try and make something
happen so Andy and I pitched Aaron
Spelling a show that is going to make
the two of us
primetime Superstars and we took a quick
we took a camera crew along with us to
the meeting so you could see what
happened let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. spelling I want to start off by
saying Andy and I are thrilled to get
this meeting with you this is an
incredible privilege beautiful place
good to see you guys big fan we have the
perfect idea for you oh it's got Aaron
Spelling written all over it
yeah great idea it's got Aaron Spelling
written on it twice this is such a great
idea and we think if Aaron Spelling
joined forces with the conan and andy
team we could put a show on the air that
would not only be in the top five it
would be in the top two it would be the
top one is one above that top one we
could possibly meet the top one in two
if you showed it twice hey I can't wait
come on it's called woman island all
right woman either
woman island beautiful beautiful women
how beautiful are the women the ugliest
woman on woman island is 20 times better
looking and Heather Locklear and there
are two guys that live there bingo-bango
you guys live there I am I'm kind of the
guy that runs woman Island I'm kind of
the mr. Roarke I'm mysterious I don't
wear a shirt that's explained in the
later episode I kind of run things I'm
sort of a mr. Roarke and and and he will
be tattoo no I'm not tattoo I don't know
you're not tattoo you're Bongo
he's Bongo I'm Bongo what happens is
whenever the volcano erupts the women
get really oh I'm scared and they they
gather around me and Bongo oh hey ladies
take it easy you know calm down the
volcano I've checked it it's gonna be
okay and I love you
we actually thought we've had hair to my
arms because they're not real hairy but
like bongos like all man so like we'll
get like instead of like hair plugs on
your head we'll get them all over my
arms and just those hairy arms around
the ladies will yeah well I thank God
you know no lava
I think we're getting sort of hot I mean
bong right cuz we're talking about bongo
oh sorry go ahead and sure this man
[Music]
the whole toll of them but pretty much
that's the song
mr. spelling what do you think gentlemen
I like it it sounds great and we'll get
my writers and producers in there I want
them to hear it all okay really good all
right gentlemen pitch times over with
let's go no no no that's it we're done
you're hurting my arm but we're doing a
show called lemon Island with it nope
that's it no writers today we're
supposed to talk to mr. Spelling about
[Applause]
[Music]
watch without woman island it's gonna be
on UPN I think we'll take a break when
we come back gotta stick around tonight
Ben Affleck's here we're in Los Angeles